hello you look amazing first of all
you're smiling you're glowing
thank you so much i got sleep last night
i'm
so sore though but thanks i mean just
like carrie ann said it was shocking and
surprising
that you were eliminated now that you
had a chance to sit with it
has it been shocking and surprising that
you were with the result
and what happened i mean to be honest
with you i think
it's opposite what i would have thought
in the moment it was a little less
shocking you know i felt like
um you know going into the night i knew
you know how crazy it was that it was
going to shrink so much and
and then when i i saw who was left on
the floor it was me
and skye and and neve and so i think i
was less shocked in the moment
than i am like today where it's like you
don't have that
schedule to report to you and you kind
of you know it's just a little more like
oh my gosh i you know i i wasn't
prepared for it even though you
feel like you know it's gonna happen it
still feels like oh man
i know and you're talking about the
soreness how was your experience on
dancing with the stars
what was that feeling before you got on
the the dance floor what was
what was the whole dynamics for you
well that's the one thing i will say
again it's very opposite what i would
have thought i would have thought that i
would um
feel less sore today because i had
yesterday off but there's something
about working through it i guess
every day showing up and kind of working
through the soreness that maybe was
making it better because i'm not kidding
today was the source i've ever been
and we didn't do anything yesterday so i
was like wow i can't move
anywhere but um just the dynamics of it
all it's just
it kind of feels like the highest of
highs you know and of course it's
super disappointing at this point but
i'm so proud of you know
what we did and i couldn't possibly
you know have imagined that that's what
we would have looked like when we
started this so i'm i'm very happy
yeah you were amazing on the dance floor
and there was this amazing performance
that you did and it was an emotional one
where you did a tribute to your parents
i mean that must have been so special
for you
you know and that's one of those things
i'll just never forget that's such a
lifetime
memory that i'm so grateful to have um
you know and it it was so therapeutic
and it was such a
you know a beautiful tribute to take
pain and turn it into art and
it's just something that will always
mean so much to me and i'm so
grateful for the show for all of those
different memories that i've had but for
sure nothing will top that one
and you said this this was an experience
that was therapeutic it kind of freed
you
as you're moving on to your next chapter
in your life i mean this experience
how are you doing mentally and how are
you coping spiritually
oh my gosh well mentally i feel like i i
have to
you know it's going to take me a couple
days to be like okay wait let me go back
to
you know i had a life before this let me
re-enjoy yeah
because it's very um you know it really
does take over your life
and um you know spiritually it's just
i'm so grateful like that is the
overwhelming feeling that i have
i couldn't have imagined um this
experience
and it's just you know i'm leaving with
so many friendships and
and just so i mean confidence even just
things like that that you just can't put
a price on you couldn't go by and so
um i think that's that kind of
encompasses where i'm at right now
super grateful super happy and you know
very sore
very sorry yeah and it sounds like
you've come out as a new woman
when you said the word confidence i mean
this is you know this is what it's all
about is these challenges and coming out
of it and finding a positive angle to it
uh are you ready to meet new people are
you ready to answer those dms are you
ready to mingle
i am i mean listen now i'm in shape i've
got time on my hands okay
now's the time i'm ready i'm so excited
for you because that that's what it's
all about is taking these experiences
and making something out of it and even
while watching the show there were some
really emotional moments with jeannie
mai who also just recently told us she's
out of surgery and she's doing well have
you had a chance to connect with her
i have you know i feel like jeannie is
just such a light and she is
um you know always so supportive of
everyone and i feel like
we really have just been such a
supportive group to each other
there's not been that you know of course
people are like playfully competitive
but we all love each other and
um we flooded her with love and you know
support and i hope you know that she
really felt that because
nobody wants somebody to leave like that
i mean not one person
would have been happy that that's how
you know she left we were heartbroken
for her and
uh just so happy that she's feeling
better that is the most important thing
that's the most important thing and our
canadian girl caitlyn bristow do you
guys have a chance to get to know each
other and
do you talk about the bachelorette
you know it's funny i'm actually doing
her podcast after this i love you
so much yes i mean we've just become
friends we
i loved her anyways but kind of through
instagram before this we'd had like a
couple like dms and stuff
and through this show it really is like
camp you bond with each other
um you know your screen the ballroom's
empty you know it's just
us and the crew so we are screaming so
loud for each other
half of that you'll never see on the
show because while they're dancing
you know they're filming the dance but
we want them to feel you know that they
have
support in the ballroom so we're over
there screaming our lungs out
and um you know we do it for each other
and she's just the best i think she's
such a beautiful dancer
and i hope she goes all the way oh would
you ever do the bachelorette
oh my gosh you know everybody keeps
asking no really people asking about
that would you
well because uh an executive came out
and let let the cat out of the bag i was
set to do it like 10 years ago
if brad womack had picked someone up
okay he seized it
and so that kind of made headlines and
so you know now when people ask me that
normally of course i would say no
because that sounds so terrifying but
listen
at this point in my life i say i'm open
to whatever
i don't know what the future holds but
i'm coming from a place of yes so
you know we'll see what happens you know
the fact that you're talking to caitlin
after this
i have to ask because she recently
talked about the fact that carrie anne
has been a little bit
too harsh with her critiques and that
she finds it a little bit personal
do you feel that way i don't feel that
way
but you know everyone's experience is
different i really felt like they were
trying to give constructive criticism i
first of all i know i had a lot to
improve on you know kaitlyn and i are
very different dancers so i can't even
compare her experience to mine
for me i really felt like they were
trying i i really felt like they wanted
me to do better and i
and i was giving everything i had each
week and i wanted to
take the criticism and try and you know
um put it towards
you know put it to work and really kind
of show them each week and
i think you know it's hard when you're
putting your whole heart out there to
get those criticisms
it's it's tough and it's got to be hard
for them because you may
enjoy watching it but you still have to
you know give
you know criticism so yeah so carrie
anne's a pretty good judge then she's
making comments to help you with your
with your game i mean i i felt like that
for me personally i can only speak for
myself but i really felt like all of the
judges were always trying to be positive
and give
like critiques that can help you for the
next week
now selling sunset i'm assuming all your
friends
from the show were rooting you on who's
your your uh
the biggest cheerleader oh my gosh i
think
um you know it's probably you know you
just saw jason and mary on the show
and um you know but honestly also
i feel like maya and amanza and
um you know i just feel like they've all
kind of been heather
i got the most beautiful flower bouquet
from her today
it's just so sweet they've honestly all
been yeah just so
um so amazing so hopefully you know i'll
get to teach them some dance steps next
time we're out
yeah and i have to ask you because i
love the show so much did davina connect
with you has she apologized to you
well i'm not really holding my breath
for that but that's okay
you know we're you know it is what it is
at this point you know you have
colleagues that you work with you're not
necessarily friends with and
i wish her all the best there's no bad
blood whatsoever
um but you know it would probably come
acro we don't keep in contact that way
yeah
yeah and season four are you shooting
well i can't say you know netflix really
likes to be in charge of
uh making those announcements i'm sorry
the second i can say something i will i
promise
but you're excited about season four i
would be excited
to you know continue the show because i
think it's such a success people love it
you know i think um
and there's a lot more to tell i mean we
we're so busy right now
yeah what brings you joy
oh my gosh well you know the show just i
mean i can't even explain to you how
crazy and fun that was so that dancing
with the stars
100 was one of the most fun experiences
i've ever had
and so now i don't want to lose that you
know dancing i realized
really did bring me a lot of joy so i
want to try and find ways that i can
incorporate it you know
going forward i don't want to just never
dance again so
i'm going to try and keep it up a little
bit what's the coolest dance move you've
ever learned
from dad's dancing with the stars um
i think i think the moves that i
initially thought i wouldn't be able
i think the moves that i thought i
wouldn't be able to do initially
like when he first told me about jumping
off the stage into his arms and then
uh he showed me this fly where i you
know the other girl was flying in the
air and i just remember both times being
like i'm not going to be able to do that
and of course
as you go along you do and you watch it
you're like oh it's so cool so i think
any of the jumps that initially i was
like i can't do that
oh that's awesome thank you so much for
chatting with us congratulations to you
coming this far and and it's so nice to
see you smile and just
enjoying it all so we really appreciate
watching you so thank you
thank you so much great talking to you